and please bear with us while i get our
live stream started i'm stuart creek i'm
in the marketing department here at
simply learn
so
it'll take me just a few minutes to get
this process started
oh
live on linkedin
and i will begin the presentation now
not audible
i'm sorry i'm not speaking
all right
and welcome everyone
stuart creek from marketing department
at simply learn
and welcome to our career master class
how to build a personal brand and unlock
career success
our speaker today is simasa hai a career
security coach and author
uh before we introduce sema
i would like to point out
that you can put questions for her into
the q a panel
at the
controls in the right hand column
click on the q a to open that
window and you'll see the box to enter
your question
you can use the chat window if you like
um we tend to spend more time with the q
a
but i know that sema may ask some
questions about you
for the chat so
find that with a little speech bubble at
the lower right
and
we're also going to be asking a couple
of poll questions
during the
presentation so the first one i'd like
to ask
very straightforward which is
how many years of experience
in the workplace do you have
and we also like to ask a companion
question
we've been asking it throughout the
pandemic how are you doing today
i know that
surges rising and falling with lockdowns
coming and going
it can be
confusing and stressful time
and it's been going on for quite a while
so we like to check in with people with
that
and we'll give you another 15 seconds
and we'll close the poll in about five
seconds from now
and
here are your answers
so we have a
good portion of the audience that's got
more than 10 years of experience about
two
two-fifths
and the rest is distributed
among the other experience levels
it's also good to see that nearly
everybody is saying that they're doing
well or doing okay
and hopefully what sema has to say for
you today is
going to
help you if you're in the could be
better category so
without further ado let us introduce
sema
seema
she is a
uh secure career security and
enhancement coach an author a consultant
a trainer
over 23 years of experience
in helping people
and she's got
uh
excellent resume so i'll let her speak
more to herself as i
transfer
the
control of the sharing over to her
and she'll be able to share her
presentation
okay sima take it away
right uh is that visible am i audible
you're visible audible and we're seeing
your slide presentations
thank you so much stuart thank you for
the introduction and always a pleasure
to be here on this platform of simply
learn
and hello everyone uh hope to have a
very nice time with all of you in this
master class
so uh not much of an introduction i
would like to give today because it's
all there on the screen
uh however i would like to say that yes
i have been in this field for over 23
years now and uh today i am going to be
presenting
on this topic uh
one second
yes how to build a personal brand and
unlock career success in 2022
so
what's in a name a rose by any other
name would smell as sweet so said
shakespeare one of the most iconic
playwrights of all times in his play
romeo and juliet
but that was in the 16th century
today however it's all in the name or
should i say it's all in the brand and
that is brand you
so who hasn't heard of people like oprah
winfrey or
elon musk or tony robbins or even
shahrukh khan
all of us have
all these individuals are in themselves
very powerful rats
so is personal branding only for the
celebrities
no it is for everyone
because whether we like it or not all of
us have already a brand which we project
to the world
however
this brand is not consciously created so
today i'm going to be talking about the
key dimensions or the key skills on how
to create a personal brand and how to
unlock your career success how to have
an immensely successful
professional journey
so what is personal branding
now very often it is misconstrued or
mistaken as your appearance as your
outward image as your um
vanity your outfits your clothes uh your
style uh you know uh and even the need
for you to be present 24 7 promoting
yourself in order to make a name for
yourself
so personal branding is not about how
polished you look it is also not about
how many followers you have on insta or
facebook
it is about how people perceive you it
is about how you're creating a brand a
unique brand for yourself
and that is as i said brad you
so as i said it is for everyone all of
you amazing professionals experienced
people executives people who are not yet
working people who are working and want
to make amazing careers for themselves
people from all spectrums of
life people from all age groups so
personal branding is for those who want
to do more it is for those who want to
go beyond their routine existence and
create a great impact on people through
their personal social and professional
lives
so uh basically what is now your
personal brand it is about presenting
yourself it is about uh
how you uh how how your image is
reflected to the outside world but it is
not about your superficial presentation
it has to depict your authentic self
what you are from the inside
your true self and what are the values
you hold all these things need to be
depicted in your personal brand and how
this thing is reflected outside
and so it cannot be fake because uh you
know you cannot project something which
you are not so your personal branding
has to be aligned to your true self or
otherwise you will soon be found out so
again it is not a fame game it is not a
10 minutes under the spotlight it is not
you being constantly you know or not
even constantly you being the flavor of
the
season so to say so it is much more
long-lasting and impactful and extensive
so uh it consists of three components
personal brand has three important
elements the first is
your unique perspective so um i mean
what is you have to find out what is
unique about you uh what is your
perspective what is your mindset what is
your thought process and how is it
different from others
the second is your value as an expert
what kind of value do you provide to
people and not just to all the people
people whom you want to specifically
address and that is your um your target
audience so are you providing enough
value to them and the third of course is
long-lasting impact so are is your
personal brand leaving a long-lasting
impact on people uh does it i mean does
it have the power is it powerful enough
to outlive you is it powerful enough to
leave a lasting legacy so these are the
few things which you have to consider
when you are planning or
you know designing your personal brand
so it is a reputation that you create in
a very very strategic manner and uh it
has to reflect because you are an expert
in your domain it has to reflect how you
are doing things in a different manner
how you're doing things in a new manner
and how you're doing things in a more
innovative manner than what others are
doing in the same field or in similar
roles so this is what differentiates you
now let me ask you a quick question
how many of you want to create an
awesome personal brand for yourself if
you can answer in the chat box please
type brand
and
answer answer that question for me
please
okay brand yes raja rao mukesh
sunita anil
thank you so much thank you so much for
your response and now the next question
how many of you want to create uh this
unique brand and also become immensely
successful in your careers please type
me in the chat box if you want to do
that
i can see a lot of responses coming in
thank you so much thank you so much
everyone is typing me thanks so much for
the response so here goes
now
how do you create a unique personal
brand it is actually a three pronged
process and uh it is you can do it by
following what i call my three e formula
and what is the 3e formula it is explore
engineer and execute
so explore what your hidden talents are
explore your strengths explore your uh
uh you know what you are good at and uh
you know you have to sort of be very
clear about your career course right
from the day one be clear about the
career goals with regards to your skill
sets with regards to your strengths with
regards to your interest what is it that
drives your passion so be very clear
about that and explore all these things
and what are your personality traits
what attributes do you want your
personal brand to have and before that
why do you even want to have a personal
brand what is the purpose behind it so
is it uh is it because maybe if you're a
student not yet working is it because
you're looking for your dream job and if
you're working is it because you want to
change your job or you want a different
role so be very clear about all these
aspects and then explore what and how
you want to create your personal brand
the next is of course engineer now here
is where you plan and design your
personal brand so uh you have to uh
actually uh you know according to your
professional goals you have to see uh
whatever you are communicating whatever
message you are giving out whether
online or offline is it in consonance
with your professional goals so is are
you saying something which you really
want to do which you really want to
achieve so it has to be in
in consonance with that now uh because
we are now working in a hybrid model and
uh it is not just online but it is also
now in person offline so is your
visibility there in both the in in both
the spaces so your
you do not need to just be online you
also have to make a great impression
offline so see if that your visibility
is there your charisma is there in both
the spaces and also define your
audiences as i said you cannot you
cannot address everyone so you have to
define your target audience
so again as i said if you are looking
for a job if you are looking to get a
job who is your audience are they the
recruiters are they the hr people are
the organizations are the employers who
are they and where are they present so
which which channels are they present on
and accordingly have your presence over
there
so uh in order to uh you know again uh
widen your your reach you can think of
starting a podcast uh you can think of
starting a youtube channel you could
even think of writing a book and believe
me people who uh you know people who
have written a book uh actually authors
are viewed as uh people having a great
authority so and uh i can also vouch for
that because a book is one of the best
forms of a visiting card or a business
card so these are the things you need to
engineer and
start working on your personal brand and
the third step of course is execute so
after you have
after you have designed your personal
brand you need to execute and execute
your plans very very diligently now this
is the personal branding the whole
process is uh you know a very deliberate
process it is not an overnight
phenomenon so it is uh it is time taking
it is a very conscious process and it
will as i said take time but but if you
are focused if you are diligent before
long you will become the go-to expert in
your field or in your domain
so
in this connection let me take you to a
matrix a four quadrant matrix uh okay am
i not visible
or is it that i am not audible what is
it
uh you're visible in audible i think if
uh i'll send a message out to people if
they have trouble hearing
people are saying i'm visible as well as
audible okay uh maybe
i can
okay so this is the fourth quadrant and
the first quadrant consists of low
expertise and high visibility so what
does this mean we see this all around us
on the on the internet people who are
low in their expertise that is they do
not have the knowledge but still they
are their present everywhere so in the
long run it does not prove to be very
very fruitful the second quadrant is low
expertise and low visibility so here
neither the expertise is there nor the
visibility is there the third quadrant
is high expertise and low visibility so
here you might be a master of your
subject you might have immense command
in your niche area in your area of work
but you do nothing to project yourself
to the world so people around you might
know you as uh as an expert but since
you do not project it outside you have a
very low visibility
and that is why you remain unheard and
unknown and the fourth quadrant is what
we are all aiming at it is the ideal
quadrant where we have high
high expertise as well as high
visibility so it is there and this is
the thing this is the quadrant which we
all should aim at so following this
quadrant based on this matrix you can
craft
an awesome uh you know professional
journey for yourself so if you are a
student how will you do it uh you know
you can uh because we are living in
these present times you can leverage the
use of the internet and create a very
strong identity for yourself and uh you
if you want to talk about something if
you have an abiding interest if you have
a passion if you have a skill which you
want to talk to about talk about to the
world then you can do that and you can
easily create a create a great identity
for yourself and uh by the way uh you
know 70 percent of the hr people uh look
for uh look for uh online candidates
look for online applicants uh you know
and that is why these people have
greater opportunities of uh
getting the required job and also uh 90
of the recruiters they feel that because
of the job market becoming so
competitive a person who has a good
online presence always stands to get a
good job so these are the things again
that you should keep in mind and
so this was about the student now if you
are a working professional then
what is that exclusive value that you
bring to your organization ask this
question because domain expertise is a
given it is always going to be very big
and that is why you are working in your
organization in that particular role but
what is it that sets you apart from the
others so you need to ask yourself that
and also you can ask
what is that one problem that i can
solve for my uh industry or for my
organization or in my career so these
are the things you can ask and work on
and you will definitely make a name for
yourself and if you are a seasoned
professional and that is you have a
number of years of experience then you
can ask yourself how can i combine my
expertise and my skill sets and my
experience of various industries and
create something valuable create
something innovative in my present
organization so these are the things
that can
uh you know give you uh give you that go
to uh expert kind of a visibility and
charisma so these are the things now uh
i will talk about
certain skills so certain skills that
can again amp your unique brand so how
what are those skills that will lend you
an edge in your professional growth of
course there are a lot of skills we can
talk about so many functional career
skills but today i will be concentrating
i will be focusing on three important
skills uh which are which are you know
uh very very crucial to bring uh to
build your
personal brand
so uh
the first skill that i will be focusing
on is intellectual curiosity so up till
now i have been focusing on how you
should be a master of your domain how
you should be an expert in your niche
but it also pays to go beyond that it
also pays if you appreciate different
schools of thought you know if you
appreciate uh different people's
opinions
on any issue because any issue might
have different kinds of opinions and uh
you should be able to uh sort of
appreciate all these different kinds of
opinions and schools of thought so what
is the advantage here is that when you
communicate when you communicate again
either online or offline if you post
something online then your perspective
will have a much richer and a much more
mature understanding than others so this
is why we should develop intellectual
curiosity and what are the ways to
develop intellectual curiosity the first
thing of course is reading be a
voracious reader
so
you can read books across various genres
that will uh that will
that will make learning very pleasurable
and it will really fuel your thirst for
knowledge so reading is one thing the
other thing is that you can learn at
least two three skills apart from your
domain skills apart from the skills that
you already know so anything that is
interconnected sort of to your skill uh
to your main skill or your poor skill
you can master that and that will give
you a lot of authority so these are the
ways in which you can uh you know sort
of uh
become intellectually superior to the
others and this is what is going to set
you apart it will give you a heads up
when people are looking for uh you know
such profiles either online or even for
people for uh when you are writing your
resume
or when you are appearing for your
interviews it will lend you an edge
because you are coming from a place
which is very well thought out and very
well researched and the others are not
coming from that kind of
of an advantage so it will make a very
great impact on that
so this is the first skill and then the
second skill is of course executive
presence now how many of you have heard
of this term executive tips can i get an
ep in the chat box
and ep if you have heard the term
executive presence yes so a lot of us in
the corporates have heard of that
elusive
yes okay of that elusive uh
you know
that x factor which is called executive
presence now these are the kind of
people who stay calm under pressure
these are the kind of people who make a
great first impression why because they
are genuine and they lack any pretenses
of any kind and of course they are
committed workers they are knowledgeable
they have a lot of gravitas uh and a lot
of authority and uh because they are
because they are creative thinkers their
solutions to problems are again very
well thought out and uh that is why they
get the opportunity to lead and execute
their ideas so captain pool that's right
so uh in short executive presence is
your ability to inspire trust and
confidence in others
now if i'm talking about your
subordinates then uh
your you know people who are people who
are working under you do you inspire
them enough that they are ready to
following and if i'm talking about your
colleagues your peers then do they find
you reliable and uh you know capable of
handling situations and if i'm talking
about your
superiors your bosses your managers do
they feel that you have that potential
of you know being given challenging
assignments being being given more
important roles or in short being given
more uh you know a leadership role in
the organization so uh these are the
things which you have to develop in
yourself in order to have an executive
presence and it might seem like a very
tall order for one person to have but
believe me it is a skill like any other
skin
it is an acquired skill it is not an
inherent one and you have to
you have to work on it with dedication
and with consistency and soon you will
have that x factor in you which is
called
executive presence and this is the
difference when you reach your mid
career level this is going to make the
difference on whether you're going to go
ahead and get that leadership role or
whether you're going to stay and
stagnate in your places
in your you know place where you are so
this is the second skill you should be
thinking of and then we come to the most
important skill of all and that is of
course communications now this is a very
wide umbrella because it consists of
your non-verbal your verbal intelligence
it consists of your oral your written
your digital communication it consists
of so many things but today for the
purpose of personal branding i am going
to be focusing on the two aspects of
communications and that is
the first one is
active listening and the second one is
going to be public speaking
so what
now we have often heard this term
activeness
how can listening be active now active
listening is when you listen to the
other person
for the purpose in order to understand
what that person is actually trying to
convey so you are listening to the
person with empathy with attention and
you are reading and you are
understanding not just the words that
the person is uttering but also the
subtle nuances of the underlying meaning
you know the underlying meaning behind
what is left unsaid so these are so
these are the things which only a person
who is very very
understanding very very uh empathetic
towards others can do so develop this
quality of active listening and in the
process you will have great inter
interpersonal relationships with your
people around you in your organization
and of course you will develop that
quality of empathy towards others so
this is uh active listening the second
of course is very important and that is
public speaking
now here public speaking by that i don't
mean uh you you need to be a very fine
orator now public speaking means
everything you know it means your
communication in public it means your
communication the way you talk in your
workplace it means your communication
with your subordinates with your
colleagues with your peers with your
with your superiors whether or not you
can inspire other people uh to your
thoughts to your way of thinking whether
or not i suppose it's a it's a it's a
sales meeting or a client meeting
whether or not you can negotiate in a
very effective manner
uh all these things constitute uh public
speaking and it is not just uh you know
about you being a very good orator so uh
so these are the three skills according
to me the three power skills that can
take your brand to another level all
together
so now
um let me just pause for a moment and if
i can request stewart to
share the form and i would request
everyone to quickly fill up that form
and submit it please it will hardly take
30 seconds so stuart if you can share
that form
right and everyone should look into the
chat window i am sending it
now
yes uh
just filling up fast i mean
hardly take 30 to 45 seconds
okay put it dry all good
okay great so now with that we come to
the second section of this master class
and that is how to build your personal
brand on the digital platform so that is
of course these days very very important
now according to data reporter almost 5
billion people worldwide are on the
internet and of course as we know the
pandemic has only served to increase
these numbers
so
the days of pitching by flyers by you
know
what you call uh those brochures and
pamphlets all those days are gone if you
want your your reach to be whiter that
is
and so
how do we do it what we do is
we instagram what we eat
we pinterest what we wear and we
celebrate our pet's birthday on facebook
nothing wrong with that visibility is
crucial but what you must remember is
that whatever you are posting is again
in accordance with the image or with
your personal brand that you're trying
to
try to create or that which you have
already created you have cultivated so
keep that in mind always and always be
uh careful of the kind of experience you
are providing to your audience to your
niche to your target audience so to see
so now let us look at
some of the various platforms where you
can build your uh awesome
personal brand and the first of course
is twitter now this is primarily as you
all know it is an opinion platform where
if you have a perspective on any issue
you can share it
and i personally like twitter because it
is a very uh very effective way of
content content creation and because the
character limit is only 280 so you are
forced to think before you tweet and
that is why it teaches you the brevity
of expression and that is why twitter is
one of the i mean one of the best way of
content creation for me and it teaches
you brevity it teaches you how to share
your ideas in a very effective and
concise manner
the next of course is instagram
very popular but very erroneously termed
as a fun and activity platform or mainly
a visual delight platform there are so
many serious influencers on on instagram
who are doing tremendous work so it is
not just fun and games over there
now if your target audience is there or
if you want to make your presence
spelled on instagram you need to keep
your bio optimized now this is the first
thing your bio and your profile pic
those are the two things which everyone
which everyone notices the moment they
uh you know scroll through instagram and
land on your profile so if your bio is
uh
is optimized and it has all the things
briefly again there is a limitation of
characters that you can use uh
limitation of space is there so project
your bio as you would your elevator
pitch so in 30 seconds you have to say
whatever you want to say about yourself
in your elevator page similarly in
limited space say what you want to say
about what you do showcase your
challenge showcase your work
on your instagram buy and of course end
it with a call to action that is very
very important the cta is very important
you could add a link to your website you
could add a link to your landing page
a link to your event probably which you
are hosting uh or anything uh one of
your courses if you have a course uh if
not you can have a link free account now
link tree account if people click on
that you will be taking them you will be
directing them to all the other
platforms where you have a presence on
so this is instagram
very very briefly now the next platform
of choice for us is youtube now don't we
all know that it is the second largest
search engine after google and as such
it has immense reach and immense
potential so it has entertainment it has
education it has infotainment it has
news uh it has various panel discussions
and of course videos of all kind so if
you make really great content and
consistently on youtube the seo will
pick it up and very soon you will have a
large
network a large following and very wide
reach on youtube
the next of course is the original
branding platform the original personal
branding platform facebook and all of us
started with this tend to be so here
there are so many options and facebook
has made rockstars of so many people so
you can use
facebook groups you can use facebook
pages uh and you can use facebook
business here there are endless options
uh for
creating your brand on facebook and one
thing which i would just like to point
out very quickly is that facebook page
we all have a facebook page or more more
or less everyone has
but on that facebook page there is that
option of having a cover image now uh on
that cover image uh instead of just
just uh placing or just putting a cover
image you can use a caruso now this
option is there this feature is there on
facebook page where you can use a
carousel of at least four images four
images uh in one space so that is a big
advantage if you want to say something
about yourself about your organization
about your talents about your brand
itself so this carousel feature you can
use on your facebook page
the next platform
very new entrant to the scene and it is
really burst into the
onto the
web onto the web and very very recent
phenomena and it is called clubhouse now
this is primarily an audio platform so
where of course since it is only audio
your content needs to be great but apart
from that uh apart from the content
because uh you know you are discussing
serious and targeted topics on this you
know your chosen topics and you're
having discussions in the club rooms on
this uh in this platform so apart from
your great content the manner in which
you communicate the manner in which your
you present or your tonality or your
articulation all these things need to be
very good on clubhouse and also the
manner in which you drive engagement in
the room for instance if you're
discussing about a book let's say
the four four hour work week the four
hour work week by tim ferriss i'm sure a
lot of you have read that so if you are
discussing something about books and
authors you can ask the people you can
draw out the people and ask them
have you read this book what do you
think of it do you agree with the author
so instead of monopolizing the
conversation you need to engage everyone
else in the room you can even ask them
if they have not read the book uh what
book are they presently reading or uh
which is their who is their favorite
author so things like that and very soon
you will be uh you will become very
popular in clubhouse and you will have a
lot many followers
so
now we come to the mecca of personal
branding and that is linkedin so
linkedin is one of the most powerful
professional networking platforms and it
has 810 million members spread over 200
countries so it provides immense value
it provides great content creation and
knowledge sharing so to build an
impactful and stellar profile on
linkedin i will not i will now give you
nine steps to build a great profile now
these nine steps uh you know
actually constitute the nine sections of
your linkedin profile and uh if you have
all these covered you will definitely
set us yourself up to greater heights as
far as your personal branding is
concerned
so let us quickly look at all these nine
sections or the nine steps the first of
course being your profile picture now
profile picture is the first thing as i
said
is what people look at so uh your
profile picture over here in linkedin
has to be a professional headshot you
cannot have a casual profile picture and
remember uh that professional headshot
you need to have a smiling deminer it
cannot be a dead stare because you know
uh with your picture if your picture is
warm and inviting people feel prepared
to stop and look at the rest of your
profile so have a very nice nicely short
professional headshot and also there is
another option instead of uh i mean
apart from a profile picture you can
have a video also so that is a 30 second
video option so when you click on the
profile picture there is an option to
upload a video as well so that can be an
introductory video for yourself and you
can be talking directly to your uh
target audience in that so make use of
it the next of course is cover image
now here i would like to ask a question
how many of you have kept that cover
image blank
how many of you have left that covered
image blank because a lot of us do not
bother to put up any cover image at all
yes so he's typing
he has left it blank and swapna has left
it blank now this is a real waste of uh
what should i say a real estate on
linkedin so never leave it blank you can
add uh you know your areas of expertise
if you don't want to add an image you
can add your areas of expertise on
in this space and because text is also
allowed so you can add that as far as
the pick is concerned the picture is
concerned you can add any picture that
depicts you in action so for example um
you could be uh you know
action meaning you could have organized
an event and you can put a picture of
that in your cover image uh you can put
a picture of your organization and you
working over there in your cupboard
which anything but and everything
will do but do not leave it blank
so uh yes the third is your headline now
this is your brand positioning so this
should be very succinct and very clear
because again the limitation of
characters is always there so you can
have headlines in two ways uh the first
way is of course to have a
very routine corporate kind of a
headline which uh which mentions your
various roles and all these rolls are
separated by those vertical separators
so that looks very neat and uh very very
orderly another way is instead of just
mentioning the various roles and the
various positions that you hold you can
say in one sentence i help uh
for instance i can say i help
one million people achieve or acquire
their dream jobs so you can do that that
will be more catchy so be very creative
when you can when you are making your
headline so that is another thing now
the fourth section is of course very
important and that is about you what we
call the summary section now here also
you can write about yourself in several
ways you can write about yourself in a
in a in the form of a story and uh what
your journey has been what your
professional as well as personal journey
has been
because there is a lot of space and
there is a lot of a lot of text that you
can write
in this section so uh write about your
achievements your accomplishments your
various career trajectories where all
have you worked what have you achieved
what are the results and where you are
at present so you can mention all these
things and uh if you do not want to
write this kind of an essay this kind of
a story then you can write in bullet
forms or in the forms of a few points
let's say about five or six points um
at this describing your various
interests your various roles and your
various skill sets so that will again be
in the form of bulleted points uh if not
uh you should uh
use you can combine both these things
together and give a short story in the
in the beginning and in the remaining
space you can give a bullet uh your uh
you know bullets or points about your
skill sets your skill sets your
achievements your accomplishments all
that can come in the form of bullet
points so the choice is yours but make
it a very very impressive because
recruiters often come here and read
about because that is the place where
they will find out about yourself so
they always go through your about you
section
the next is of course your featured
section and here you can add all your
audio visuals uh you know your videos
and everything uh all your achievements
your awards in fact you can make a
carousel again of all the feedback uh
wonderful feedback and
you know things are praising you
things uh which uh which show uh what a
high achiever you are so make a carousel
of all these accomplishments and put it
in your featured section and always of
course have a cta or a call to action
you can take them you can take your
visitors to the website or to any other
site any other platform that you want
them to for instance for me the featured
section consists of my book and all the
all the activities around my book so if
it is a show talk show featuring my book
i put that video over there the link to
my book my amazon that is there so you
can do a lot of things in your feature
section and it is literally your hall of
fame so make it attractive make it
lively and make it picturesque the next
is experience and this is generally uh
mainly only for professionals i mean of
course others can also do it um but it
is good for professionals and people who
are looking for jobs for students and
then here you can list all your
experiences all your
different roles that you've had
in in the form of a resume but make it a
bit more creative
the next is network so we all talk about
how important it is to have how
important
it is to have a great network on
linkedin and uh you know we keep on
increasing we keep on increasing our
network and we do not really pay
attention to what kind of people we are
adding in our connections so here
according to the linkedin gurus there is
a formula and that formula is to follow
the 50 is to 30 is to 20 principle so
this 50 30 20 rule what does it mean it
means that 50
of your connections
should be those people whom you want to
target that is again your target
audience for instance if you are again
looking for a job who are the people who
are your target audience again the hr
the recruiters the hiring people the
organizations employers those kind of
people would be your target audience and
um similarly if you are a professional
who's looking to change his job or
looking for other roles the kind of
people who would be who would be helpful
for you so those are constitute the 50
the next 30 percent should be your
mentors should be people who are above
you in their lives should be people who
are above you in their careers and they
should be people whom you look up to
from whom you want to learn and uh whom
probably whom you want to follow so
these are the 30 these are the people
who constitute your next 30
and of course the final 20 could be
anyone uh anyone who interests you
anyone who has made a name for himself
or herself or um
you know anyone or it it can be a very
interesting mix of people it could also
be your potential clients so all these
people can't constitute your twenty
percent of network so uh let us all
follow this rule of 50 30 20 and grow
our connections and our network the next
section is recommendations now here
again you can ask your bosses you can
ask your
mentors you can ask your managers your
university heads your
professors whoever it is under whom you
have work you can ask them to give you a
recommendation
but here instead of just asking them to
give a recommendation you can perhaps
give them a structure on what on what
they can write on so the first thing is
your relationship with them the second
is the time period of your association
with them the third is how they have
gauged your skill sets and achievements
and fourth is the results and impact
that you have created so if you give
them this guideline they will give you a
fantastic recommendation and it always
pays you should have recommendations on
your profile the last skills we all know
how important it is to have the relevant
skills to uh to get the kind of
opportunities in our careers that we
want a very good feature in the skill
section is uh to take a skills quiz
i'm sure you're aware of that and when
you take a skills quiz it will determine
your top skills and hence it will
attract potential recruiters so these
are the nine steps that i think are
important to build a stellar linkedin
profile and in turn your personal brand
on the web so with this um
okay another question out of these nine
steps on these nine sections uh could
you tell me at least one at least one
where you need to put more effort in uh
where you feel that it is not optimal so
you need to work more on this section so
which section is it for you
uh okay about you yes florence
skill
featured featured
yes
recommendation great great thank you so
much thank you so much for your
responses
and now
uh if
experience recommendations skills
yes so i think everyone's profile pick
and cover image is optimum that is that
is really super okay now uh if i can
request before leaving if i can request
your to share a link in the chat box and
we will have some magic
so stuart can you do that
there is a link yes
that's the link to your activity
okay
so how many trucks yeah yeah so how many
of you have heard of a thing called ssi
on linkedin
ssi score please type yes if you have
heard of that
ssi
no okay so ssi is the social selling
index for
social selling index board and it tells
you how successful you are at developing
your brand so whether or not you are
networking with the right kind of people
or whether you are consistently posting
because because i keep repeating this
consistency is key so whether you are
consistently posting on linkedin and
engaging with others so if you are doing
that whether you are building
relationships so these are certain
parameters which the social selling
index board will tell you about and if
stuart has put that link in the chat box
all of you can go ahead and click on
that and you will get your ssis phone
immediately
so it is a very very
so it is a very very valuable insight on
how productive you are being on this
platform
okay 13
okay asha not bad not bad that's okay oh
65 100 and uh yes if you are between 50
and 70 it is it is uh quite commendable
but anything beyond 70 is what we should
all aim at and uh let us all work and
let us see which parameter are we
lacking on so that we take our score
higher at least to 17
so this was the magic that i wanted to
share with you the ssis board oh abdul
has got 78
excellent excellent so with that we come
to the end of this master class and
here's wishing that your brand brand you
becomes more and more visible it becomes
more and more valuable and you are
discovered more you are noticed more and
you gain more and more followers and may
your tribe increase and that is why i
wish you a very very happy personal
branding effort ahead thank you so much
okay
do we have time uh sima for questions
i have enough time i mean i have all the
time
okay
so uh we did have some questions that
came in from the audience
and um
let me start with
nitu who asks um are interested in the
healthcare area
can you offer any advice in that regard
healthcare
and healthcare yeah
and skin okay
career advice i think
uh if if she is interested in health
care uh
am i getting the question right
yeah
okay so need to uh yes health uh fitness
is uh you know health is very important
because you know if you are not keeping
good health then where is the question
of you working towards your personal
brand where is the question of you
working towards your career goals your
health both physically and mentally
needs to be at an optimum so health is
taken for granted and that is why we
have this proverb health as well because
without health you cannot take any
action at all so always you know think
about healthy eating sleep on time and
also nurture your health in the same way
in which you nurture your mind so both
your mind and your body needs to be
nurtured uh very very well because feed
your mind with positive things and it
will show in your efforts feed your body
with positive things and again it will
show in the uh you know in the awesome
health that you have so health at any
age is very important and you need to
take care of that yes okay
um
proven has an interesting question
because province says
his communication isn't
good that's the way he thinks he has
this uh idea that he doesn't have good
communication
um
that
time is always a problem for him so
how can he
overcome that thought process and think
more constructively about himself
okay so there's so here uh the problem
is the time so he is not able to manage
time well perhaps and uh so here
he's also asking about his communication
skills he thinks he doesn't have good
communications okay okay so uh as i said
a communication is one of the most
important building blocks of a personal
brand and uh not just a personal brand
communication helps you everywhere so
start small i would suggest and you know
try to uh try to first focus on your
spoken language you know spoken uh
whether it's english or whether it's any
other language that you want to focus on
it could be your mother tongue it is not
necessary you know very many people
erroneously believe that you need to
have very good english it is not that
you can express yourself in any language
but you need to
put across your views you need to put
across your thoughts in a very very
impressive and impactful manner so start
small try to talk to people around you
try to express your opinions even though
you are not a
very expressive person try to open up
and speak to people around you and uh
you know also you can take help from
professionals you can take help as i
said reading develop that cultivate that
reading habit the more you read the
better your language skills will become
and the better your language skills will
become the better your vocabulary will
become and you will be able to
incorporate the those words that you
have learned
and these words are learned seamlessly
when you read you know it's not as if
you need to go to the dictionary to find
out the meaning you will understand
through the course of your reading what
a particular word means so when you have
a great vocabulary you will not hesitate
you will gain the confidence to express
yourself in front of others so that is
about the spoken skills now as far as
the written skills is concerned again
you do not need to have uh you know very
very good grammar or you know people
focus on grammar a lot when they are
learning communications i feel it is not
very important
because there are these days so many
tools so many aids in which we can
correct our grammar so the important
thing is to express yourself well not um
concentrate on the number of
the number of words that you have in
your arsenal or the correct grammar that
you have so it takes time but always
work on your communications because it
is a very very important skill
uh alice has an interesting question
she's in the midst of a career change
she asked how can she stand out
on a with a linkedin profile what can
she do to her profile to make it
stand out
right
so
okay so she wants to change her job
probably and what she should do is
i just mentioned all the nine aspects
the nine sections now here again she
should be concentrating she should be
focusing on the
featured section the about you section
because the featured section will uh
will include all the laurels all the
achievements that she has had in the
past so it will showcase all those
things to the potential recruiter plus
about you is again the entire journey
the entire uh career trajectories the
various roles that she has had and now
she's looking for a better opportunity
perhaps now she is looking because of
her skill sets she she feels that she
can be offered another opportunity or a
better opportunity so she should keep
that in mind and
write the about you or the summary
section so these are the things that she
can you know keep
keep all the nine sections at an optimum
when she is looking for a career switch
this is what can be done
okay
um we have one last question before we
have to move on
and then that is we've got a number of
people who have asked about specific
career
or industries and domains
and um do you have advice for how
somebody
should brand themselves within their
particular industry whether it's uh
whether it's the
technology industry or education
industry
or
even a question came in from someone who
wants to be an animator
how would you address that
yeah okay so the first thing as i said
whichever industry you are from
learn to be an expert at your job you
know you have to be an expert in your
niche you have to be an expert in that
industry which you belong to because
there are so many people who have these
technical skills these four skills what
is that thing what is that exclusive
thing that sets you apart from the
others so you need to focus on that and
you need to think in a different manner
think in an innovative manner to
distinguish yourself to differentiate
yourself from the other so this is the
first thing that you of course you need
to be an expert you need to have an
expertise in your industry but also make
yourself more visible also uh provide
enough value you know value is very very
important because people who have the
expertise if they do not provide that
same value to others then the whole game
is lost so personal branding itself
means the kind of value and experience
you can provide to others so that they
think you are an expert
and you can project yourself as an
expert in this manner so provide enough
value and of course be an expert in your
field and you will have an awesome
personal brand for yourself
i'm going to put into the chat window
now a number of uh
resources that
seema has shared which are
her contact information
her linkedin profile and a link to her
book
on career skills for professional
success
and
i'm going to move on to the last part
close out the webinar so thank you
everybody for your patience and for
being here
thank you very much for um
to seema for for being here
and thank you stuart thank you everyone
for joining
yeah
let me move on
we have a final poll
which asks
if you are involved in technology and
are looking to develop technology skills
which of those skills are you most
interested in learning
you can pick one or more
and the second part of the question is
very important
when will you start
that learning process
we always get a number of questions
about attendance certificates for these
webinars
but we also
want to ask you about earning actual
certificates for skills that you've
acquired
so
when are you interested in
starting that and what skills are you
looking to develop
and we've got about 10 more seconds on
the poll
and we'll close it in two more seconds
here
and
here are the results
so the most popular categories are
business and project management data
science
and digital marketing
and it's good to see that about
40 of the audience is interested in
getting started right away with another
20 or so looking to start
soon within the next three months so
with that said i'm just going to point
out
a resource that simply learn offers
which is called the skill up program and
the skill up program is free
it allows you to study
in these different
skill domains
and
you can earn certificates for completing
these self-study courses
these are sort of introductory to the
more
involved courses that we offer that
include
live virtual classrooms and hands-on
labs and that type of thing but these
skill up courses are
self-study video and
they're free you can do them on your own
schedule and they do offer completion
certificates that you can add to your
linkedin profile so
i'm going to put that information in the
chat now with the link to our
skill up
home page
and
last item i'd like to mention that we
have two more webinars this week
so if you are interested in these topics
the first one is
product management the second one is a
technical master class for digital
marketers
and
i'll put those in the chat as well
and they'll be held at the same time of
day which is 9 p.m india time and
8 30 pacific 11 30 eastern
in north america
and
with that said
i invite all of you to connect with us
on our
social media channels
at simplylearn on facebook and twitter
simply learn on linkedin
again thank you so much
to sema for being here and thank you to
everyone in the audience being here
today
all right
and that concludes our webinar
you